Salut tout le monde,
j'espère que vous allez bien.
Dans cette vidéo,
je vais vous parler d'un sujet
extrêmement difficile.
C'est les crimes de guerre
de l'armée russe, en Ukraine.
Je vous préviens,
il y a énormément d'images
très choquantes à regarder
dans ce reportage
et qui peuvent heurter
la sensibilité
de certaines personnes.
Mais c'est la réalité
de ce que j'ai filmé sur place.
À partir de la fin
du mois de mars 2022,
les troupes russes
se sont retirées
de la région de Kyiv,
mais pendant
plusieurs semaines,
ils ont contrôlé des villes
et des villages
dans lesquels ils ont commis des atrocités.
Quelques jours après
la libération de cette zone,
je suis parti sur place,
avec mes fixeurs
pour rencontrer
les Ukrainiens
et les Ukrainiennes
qui ont vécu l'occupation.
Il y a énormément
de personnes
qui essayaient de s'échapper
en voiture,
des civils
avec des enfants, etc.,
qui se faisaient tirer dessus
par les troupes russes
et il y a énormément de voitures
sur le bas-côté,
avec la carrosserie
complètement défoncée
et des impacts de balles partout.
Donc là, je viens d'arriver
à un ancien checkpoint militaire russe,
sur la route de Borodyanka,
qui a été attaqué
par l'armée ukrainienne
et repris.
Les combats ont été extrêmement violents.
Il y a une dizaine de chars,
de véhicules blindés russes
qui ont été détruits
par l'armée ukrainienne.
Il y a aussi un camp
dans la forêt.
Ils ont dû faire des pillages,
parce qu'il y a de
la nourriture ukrainienne.
Ça, c'est un chariot,
par exemple,
qu'ils ont dû remplir dans
un supermarché ukrainien
et qu'ils ont traîné
ici, jusqu'à leur camp.
Dans la plupart des tanks,
il y a des cadavres, complètement carbonisés,
des soldats russes
qui ont été tués
pendant ces combats.
Je viens d’arriver
dans une grande base
qui a été abandonnée
il y a seulement
quelques jours
par les soldats russes.
Elle se trouve à
un croisement stratégique
et vous allez voir,
il devait y avoir
beaucoup de soldats,
parce qu'il y a énormément
de constructions
qui étaient en cours
et ils ont tout laissé en plan.
Là, quand je me déplace,
vu que je ne sais pas
si ça a été déminé ici,
je regarde où je mets les pieds et surtout,
j'essaie de marcher
dans les traces des véhicules.
Il y a moins de chances
qu'il y ait des mines à
cet endroit-là, ou en tout cas,
ils les auraient
déjà fait exploser
s'ils sont passés dessus.
Dans beaucoup
de checkpoints
qu’ils contrôlaient,
les Russes
ont creusé des tranchées.
Les planches en bois
sont complètement neuves.
Et c'était pour anticiper
une contre-offensive ukrainienne
et pouvoir se protéger
des attaques.
Il y a des rations de combat russes.
Ils s'étaient même fait
un endroit pour dormir.
Ça veut dire qu'il y avait
des soldats qui
étaient postés là 24 heurs sur 24
pour surveiller
ce point de passage.
Il y a des douilles de balles
un peu partout.
Ils ont creusé
des trous profonds,
comme ça,
pour se protéger en cas
de bombardements,
de tirs de mortiers, d'obus.
Au-dessus de chaque trou,
ils recouvraient ça d'arbres
pour que ce soit plus
difficilement détectable.
C'est impressionnant.
Ils ont construit tout ça
en moins d'un mois,
mais c'était un très gros
checkpoint, ici.
Là, ils ont creusé un trou,
juste derrière moi.
Il devait y avoir
un engin motorisé,
peut-être un tank.
On peut voir les traces.
Il y avait des branches,
juste ici.
Ces branches, elles devaient servir à recouvrir l'engin
qui était juste là.
Tout a l'air encore très intact.
Il n'y a pas l'air
d'avoir eu de combats ici,
mais tout est resté tel quel.
Il y a des planches de bois,
un peu partout,
qu'ils avaient découpées.
Ils étaient en train
de commencer
à construire des choses.
Ça donne l'impression
qu'ils sont partis
en vitesse de cet endroit
et qu'ils ont tout laissé
sur place.
Sur la route et
dans les petites villes
qu'on a pu traverser,
on a vu à quel point les Russes étaient partis rapidement,
du jour au lendemain,
pour se replier à l'est du pays.
On a croisé plusieurs bases,
plusieurs checkpoints,
où ils ont tout laissé en plan.
Après, il faut savoir que
la plupart du temps,
l'armée ukrainienne,
une fois qu'elle a libéré certaines zones,
elle les nettoie.
C'est-à-dire qu'elle fait des prisonniers,
elle récupère
les documents sensibles
et en général, aussi,
elle enlève les corps
des soldats ukrainiens
qu'elle a perdus et russes.
Dans la plupart
des petits villages
qu'on est en train de traverser,
il y a un silence de mort
et quasiment tous
les magasins, les maisons
ont été endommagés
par les combats.
En fait, la plupart
des personnes,
qu'on croise dans les villages,
c’est des personnes âgées, avec une mobilité réduite,
qui pouvaient pas partir
et qui ont dû rester
pendant l'occupation russe.
Là, on est dans
la petite commune de Vorzel,
c’est juste à côté de Boutcha.
Et c’est un endroit qui a été contrôlé
aussi pendant plusieurs semaines
par les troupes russes.
Ils dormaient dans les maisons,
ils pillaient,
ils ont tué beaucoup de personnes.
Les villageois veulent nous montrer.
Ce couple, ils ont été tués par balle.
Il y a deux impacts dans le dos du mari
et selon le voisin
qui a assisté à la scène,
il nous a expliqué qu’ils avaient
interdiction de sortir de chez eux.
Ils n’avaient plus de nourriture,
donc ils ont essayé d’aller en chercher
et c’est à ce moment-là qu’ils ont été tués
par les troupes russes.
Une fois que les Russes sont partis,
c’est là qu’on a commencé
à comprendre l’ampleur
des massacres sur la population civile.
On voyait déjà un peu avant des messages
de gens sur les réseaux sociaux qui en parlaient
ou qui prévenaient leurs proches,
mais en réalité, ce n’est qu’une fois
que l’armée ukrainienne a libéré ces villes
et qu’on a pu se rendre sur place
qu’on a réalisé que tout
le monde connaissait forcément quelqu’un
qui a été victime des soldats russes
pendant l’occupation.
Et c’est pour cette raison
que les autorités ukrainiennes
ont mis en place une unité spéciale
qui est chargée de recenser
les crimes de guerre de l’armée russe
et j’ai pu les suivre à Irpin,
une petite ville au nord de Kyiv
où les combats ont été extrêmement violents.
On vient d’arriver.
Les civils qui sont ici,
ils ont été enterrés
par l’armée ukrainienne
pendant qu’il y avait encore des combats
dans Irpin, contre les troupes russes.
Et le travail des autorités est hyper important,
ils sont obligés de les exhumer
pour recenser le nombre de victimes,
s’assurer qu’ils ont bien été tués
par un bombardement.
Et ça permet de documenter
les crimes de guerre de l’armée russe.
Pour que vous compreniez
bien de quoi on parle,
il faut que je vous explique d’abord
ce qu’on qualifie de crimes de guerre.
En fait, ce sont des attaques
délibérées contre des populations civiles
ça peut être de l’enlèvement,
de l’esclavage,
des violences sexuelles,
de la torture,
des expulsions, ou encore des meurtres.
Parce que dans un conflit,
il y a évidemment des armées
qui s’opposent et s’affrontent,
mais il y a aussi quasiment toujours
des populations civiles au milieu.
Après la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
plusieurs dizaines de pays avaient décidés
de rédiger des traités
pour encadrer le droit humanitaire international,
on les appelle les conventions de Genève
et il y a évidemment plusieurs volets,
mais il y en a un qui vise spécifiquement à protéger les populations civiles
et non combattantes de toutes violences.
Et je précise qu’évidemment, la Russie,
à l’époque l’URSS,
avait ratifié ces conventions de Genève.
Je reviens sur le travail d’enquête en Ukraine
parce qu’il commence déjà
à avoir des résultats.
Un premier procès a débuté à Kyiv le 17 mai
où un jeune soldat Russe est jugé
pour avoir tué délibérément
un civil qui ne portait pas d’arme.
Il a été arrêté par l’armée ukrainienne
alors qu’il essayait de fuir la ville.
Dans ce jardin, ils ont sorti les corps
de 4 personnes
et le dernier que vous venez de voir,
c’est celui d’une grand-mère
qui a reçu des éclats d’obus dans la jambe
et qui est décédée
à cause de sa blessure.
Au moment où j’y étais,
l’unité spéciale récupérait
plusieurs dizaines de cadavres par jour.
Début avril, les autorités
ukrainiennes ont déclaré
qu’ils avaient déjà retrouvé les corps
de plus de 1222 victimes civiles
rien que dans la région de Kyiv.
Au début du mois d’avril,
il y avait tellement de cadavres
que les autorités ukrainiennes
étaient obligées de les répartir
dans plusieurs morgues, entre l’ouest
du pays et la région de Kyiv,
pour ne pas les encombrer.
Ensuite, on a continué notre route
vers Borodyanka
où les bombardements russes
ont été extrêmement intenses,
et c’est une des villes les plus détruites
par la guerre dans la région de Kyiv.
Le niveau de destruction est insensé,
il n’y a plus rien qui tient debout.
Selon l’armée ukrainienne, clairement,
les Russes voulaient faire des victimes civiles.
Quand on voit l’état de la ville, c’est difficile
de penser le contraire.
Cet appartement a été
complètement détruit.
Il reste plus rien.
Il n’y a plus personne dans cet immeuble.
Tout le monde est parti.
Là, il y a des Russes qui ont dormi ici.
Il y a des restes de leurs rations.
Ils ont essayé de pénétrer
dans tous les appartements,
il y a partout des tentatives d’effraction.
Les soldats russes sont passés par là,
ils ont mis des tags.
Il y a marqué “Vendetta”.
Je vais vous montrer mais...
sur la plupart des appartements,
ils ont aussi tagué le V,
qui est la signe de l’armée russe.
Là, certains habitants
sont revenus dans l’immeuble
juste pour récupérer ce qu’ils pouvaient
et ils vont quitter la ville.
Après Borodyanka,
on a décidé d’aller à Boutcha,
vous en avez sûrement entendu
parler dans les médias
parce que les autorités ukrainiennes
ont découvert un grand charnier
derrière l’église de la ville,
où les corps de plus de 65 personnes
ont été exhumés.
Ce qu’il faut bien comprendre,
c’est qu’un charnier comme celui-ci,
c’est une véritable scène de crime,
donc c’est pour ça qu’il y a
des enquêteurs, la police scientifique
qui essaient de récolter
un maximum de preuves
pour peut-être retrouver les responsables
qui ont commis ces atrocités,
mais ils sont aussi là pour essayer de retrouver des affaires, des effets personnels
pour confirmer l’identification de la personne
et ensuite, rendre le corps à la famille.
Les images étaient
évidemment très difficiles sur place
et on a notamment
croisé une grand-mère
qui pleurait la mort
de ses petits-enfants et de sa belle-fille
qui ont été tués alors,
qu’ils essayaient de fuir la ville.
J’espère que ce reportage vous a intéressé,
je sais, encore une fois, que ce sont des  images très difficiles à regarder,
mais je pense sincèrement
qu’il faut qu’elles existent
pour qu’on ne puisse
pas nier ces crimes.
ça me rapelle les reportages
que j’ai pu faire sur les crimes de guerre
de l’état islamique en Irak et en Syrie
et je maintiens que ce travail
de documentation est primordial et indispensable.
J’en profite aussi pour
vous dire que début juin,
sur ma chaîne YouTube,
il y aura le témoignage très fort
d’un reporter ukrainien
qui aide les journalistes étrangers sur place.
Ce fixeur a été enlevé et torturé
par les soldats russes
pendant plusieurs jours.
Il a accepté de me raconter
ce qu’il a vécu.
Fixers, c’est d’ailleurs le titre
de mon prochain docu
qui sort sur BrutX le 8 juin
et dans lequel vous allez entendre
pour la première fois
ces hommes et ces femmes sans qui
je ne pourrais pas travailler sur le terrain.
Merci encore pour tout votre soutien,
n’hésitez pas à vous abonner à la
chaîne YouTube de Brut
pour ne pas rater la prochaine vidéo.
à très vite.